todo en la experiencia humana nos ha
mostrado que las cosas tienden a caer
tanto las gotas de agua en la lluvia eh
Como las personas toda nuestra
experiencia nos ha enseñado que las
cosas caen caen es el suelo puede ser un
puñado de alfileres que caen y bueno si
te vemos por ejemplo este alfiler que ya
está en el suelo pues nunca nos
encontramos el caso de que de pronto
comience a flotar o empiece a rebotar
una vez estando en el suelo nosotros
damos por sentado que las cosas caen y
es algo que nos ha acompañado durante
toda la historia de la
humanidad es por eso que
eh el pensar diferentemente o pensar o
cuestionar algo que consideramos que es
cotidiano pues es algo realmente
eh fuera de serie y es por eso que esta
persona se ha ganado un lugar en la
historia esta persona se ha cuestionado
ese tipo de cosas cotidianas como por
ejemplo Por qué caen las cosas y sin
duda es una de las como les comenté una
de las cinco Mentes más brillantes en la
historia de la humanidad es
sir
Isaac
Newton una de sus percepciones en
relación con las cosas que caen fue
hacerse pregunta por qué tienen que caer
las cosas se dice que la inspiración
para que él se hiciera esta pregunta Le
vino al observar caer una manzana vamos
a dibujar aquí Unas
ramitas de un árbol con
hojas más o menos por acá y no es como
en muchas caricaturas este han visto que
la manzana le cayó en la cabeza eso es
muy probable que no haya pasado
así sin embargo él observó que una
manzana caía por ejemplo vamos a
imaginarnos
esta manzanita imaginemos que se rompe
esta rama y la manzana cae y bueno es
algo que vemos siempre las cosas caen
Pero él se hizo la pregunta qué es lo
que ocasiona o lo que está pasando de
manera que esta manzana tenga que caer
al
suelo Por qué la manzana
cae Esa fue la
pregunta por qué De hecho la voy a
escribir por
qué y esto lo llevó a desarrollar una
serie de pensamientos que llevaron
a a crear o a inferir la ley de la
gravitación universal él además hizo
otros descubrimientos y cualquiera de
estos los hubiera llevado lo hubiera
llevado le hubiera ganado un lugar en la
historia ya que bueno es esto es un
excelente ejemplo de cómo pensar fuera
de lo convencional cuestionar algo que
por decenas de miles de años se ha dado
por sentado Simplemente porque así ha
sucedido todo el tiempo él se preguntó
el Por qué siempre que tenía que ocurrir
así
y esta origen del pensamiento lo que es
la ley de la gravitación universal de
hecho ha Regido o son estableció las
bases para la mecánica clásica que es en
su mayor parte lo que usamos hoy en día
aunque una buena parte de esta mecánica
fue modificada o bueno revisada por este
señor de acá sin embargo para para todo
lo que hacemos en la vida cotidiana este
en la superficie de la Tierra y con
cosas que no tienen que estar o que no
se acercan a la velocidad de la luz
trabajamos con la mecánica de
Newton él no Solo intuyó que había algo
que estaba jalando la manzana o actuando
sobre ella para llevarla al suelo sino
que formuló la ley de la gravitación
universal y esta ley nos Dice que una
fuerza o existe una fuerza o un vector
fuerza entre cualquiera par de
objetos y esta fuerza es igual a una G
mayúscula que es un número muy pequeño y
es una constante la constante
gravitatoria le voy a poner aquí que es
un número muy
pequeño
número muy pequeño
y además esto se multiplica por las
masas de los cuerpos en los que queremos
calcular la fuerza la masa del cuerpo
uno por la masa del cuerpo dos y esto se
va a
dividir
entre la distancia de estos dos cuerpos
o del centro de masa de estas dos
cuerpos al cuadrado y algo extraño se
nos podría ocurrir O podría pasar por
nuestra mente al ver esta fórmula ya que
nos dice que existe una fuerza entre
cualquiera par de objetos Y bueno pues
cualquier par de objetos con masa bueno
ustedes están parados o están sentados
enfrente de un monitor de
computadora qué es lo que por qué el
monitor no sale atraído hacia su cara o
viceversa o si o por qué no su cara sale
hacia el monitor voy a dejar aquí un
monitor de
computadora lo mejor que yo pueda es un
monitor viejito no es un monitor
plano y bueno por qué no ocurre esto por
qué no se acercan los objetos hacia
nosotros s Es que de acuerdo a esta ley
Pues hay una fuerza entre cualquier era
cualquier par de objetos con
masa bueno Pues resulta que sí en efecto
hay una fuerza de atracción entre el
monitor y su rostro pero esta fuerza es
tan pequeña que la fricción que hay
entre la computadora o el monitor y el
escritorio Y ustedes y su silla es más
fuerte que esta fuerza de atracción y
pues por eso es que no se mueve
para que se den una idea de por qué esta
fuerza es casi
imperceptible les voy a comentar o les
vamos a ver que esta la constante
gravitatoria esta
G es un número muy pequeño Es
aproximadamente igual a
6.67 * 10 a la
-1 newtons newtons es una unidad de
fuerza y y la vamos a ver más adelante
un Newton Ah perdón esta fuerza
gravitatoria o esta constante
gravitatoria son esta cantidad con
unidades 10 New
por metro sobre kilog es una unidad
bastante rara pero bueno ya que
trabajemos con estos valores veremos que
es
correcta pero si se fijan es esta
cantidad por 10 a
la-1 que es un número tremendamente
pequeño si yo escribiera por acá esta
parte de 10 a la -11 sería un 0 punto 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 posiciones serían
10 ceros y un 1 Esta es la fracción
entonces est la cantidad de la constante
gravitatoria es
6.67 por
000 1
newtons
metro kilogramo al
cuadrado entonces pues bueno Esta es una
cantidad Tan pequeña que es casi ínfima
y bueno si estas masas son pequeñas Eh
Pues esta fuerza va a ser muy muy muy
pequeña qué es lo que pasa con la tierra
bueno resulta que la fuerza de gravedad
se comienza a notar porque la masa de la
tierra es enorme es tremenda este no
esta masa si pusiéramos o si
imaginárselo o bueno si nosotros
queremos calcular la fuerza de atracción
de la gravedad entre dos objetos o entre
la Tierra y algún objeto que se
encuentre en la superficie vamos a poder
eh englobar o simplificar estos
elementos la constante gravitatoria la
masa de la tierra y esta distancia esta
r que será del centro de la tierra hasta
la superficie y todo esto nos va o lo
podemos ificar con algo que se conoce
como la aceleración gravitatoria o la g
minúscula esto todo esto lo
simplificamos con esta G minúscula Y lo
multiplicamos
por la masa del objeto al que queremos
calcular la fuerza de atracción de
gravedad que hay entre este objeto y la
tierra este valor la aceleración de la
gravedad eh se ha calculado Y si estamos
hablando de algo que está eh cerca de la
superficie o en la superficie terrestre
este valor es aproximado a
9.8 m sobre segundo al
cuadrado entonces bueno con eso podemos
simplificar mucho los cálculos para algo
que está en la superficie de la Tierra
tomemos por ejemplo a una persona que
pesa 70 kg Bueno de hecho que tiene una
masa de kil vamos a ver luego más
adelante la diferencia entre peso y
masa de hecho la el peso es una fuerza
la fuerza gravitatoria o la fuerza que
ejerce la gravedad sobre la masa de
algún objeto entonces suponemos que esta
persona queremos calcular Cuál es la
fuerza con la que la tierra está jalando
esta
persona en su hacia dentro hacia ella
Entonces tenemos que queremos calcular
la la
fuerza de atracción entre esta persona
con una masa de 70 kg y eh vamos a
multiplicarla por la aceleración
gravitatoria lo multiplicamos por
9.8 m sobre segundo al cuadrado y
nuestro resultado de hecho yo ya hice el
cálculo antes pero los invito a que
ustedes lo hagan por ustedes mismos Para
que vean que este estos cálculos están
son correctos
nos da una cantidad de
kg
por metr sobre segundo al cuadrado y
esta unidad kilogramos por metr sobre
segundo al cuadrado es conocida también
como Newton en honor de esta persona que
hizo el descubrimiento e infirió la ley
de la gravitación
universal ahora permítanme hacer una
pregunta
interesante supongamos que yo voy a
posicionar a esta persona con una masa
de 70 kg en alguna parte de la tierra no
sé vamos a imaginarnos que esta persona
se
encuentra en alguna parte de aquí del
océano Índico se encuentra aquí esta
persona y ya calculamos que esta que la
Tierra ejerce una fuerza de atracción
hacia esta persona de
686 newtons ahora mi pregunta hacia
ustedes
Es acaso esta persona también está
ejerciendo alguna fuerza sobre el
planeta
tierra si esta fuerza si existe es mayor
o menor que la fuerza que la tierra está
ejerciendo sobre esta persona
Pues bueno su reacción inicial podría
ser que la tierra pues es enorme la
persona pues es una cosa muy chiquitita
y pues pareciera lógico pensar que la
Tierra ejerce una fuerza mucho mayor
sobre esta persona pero este no es el
caso de hecho ambos ejercen exactamente
la misma fuerza de atracción entre ellos
la persona también atrae a la tierra con
una fuerza de
686 New y bueno cómo es que no nos damos
cuenta o cómo es que cuando alguien
suponiendo no sé no alguien este está en
un edificio y esta
persona se le
ocurre saltar de lo alto de este
edificio si ejercen una la misma fuerza
una fuerza igual el la persona y la
tierra Cómo es que la Tierra no se
acelera hacia la persona y vemos que la
persona pues cae hacia el
suelo aquí la cuestión está en la
diferencia de masas entre la persona y
la masa de la tierra vamos a calcularlo
tenemos que bueno vamos a calcular la
masa
de bueno nuestra masa es de 600 Perdón
Nuestra fuerza es de 686
New y tenemos
que la aceleración de la
gravedad
es de
9.8 m sobre segundo cuadrado entonces lo
que queremos encontrar es cuál es la
masa de la
persona Bueno si despejamos esto nos
vamos a encontrar que la masa de la
persona es igual a los
New entre la aceleración 9.8 m sobre
segundo al cuadrado y si hacemos los
cálculos y trabajamos analizando estas
unidades nos daremos cuenta que la masa
de esta persona es de 70
kg ahora vamos a hacer el cálculo del
lado
terrestre entonces podemos analizar el
lado terrestre o bueno Qué pasa del lado
de la tierra eh También viendo esta
fórmula de que la fuerza es
igual a la masa por la
aceleración vimos que la fuerza que
existe entre la persona y la tierra es
de 686 New
y no sabemos Cuál es la aceleración pero
sí sabemos que la masa de la tierra es
enorme es un valor gigantesco en
comparación con el de la
persona por lo que para conservar esta
igualdad que esto sea igual a los 686 n
esta aceleración es imperceptible es muy
pequeña por eso es que cuando una
persona salta la persona sí se acelera
hacia la tierra y la Tierra no se
acelera hacia la persona porque bueno
esta aceleración es tremendamente
pequeñas casi cero y es bueno por eso
que esto ocurre m